vamos a continuar con un ejemplo en
donde calculemos el rotacional de un
campo vectorial particular y el campo
vectorial que quiero considerar para
este vídeo es justamente este campo b
que depende de tres variables x y y ceta
y por supuesto tenga una salida
tridimensional así que digamos que
consideremos nuestra primera componente
xy luego tomemos el coseno de zeta
y finalmente tomemos z cuadrada
más muy bien entonces este será nuestro
campo vectorial y nos preguntamos cómo
calcular el rotacional de nuestro campo
vectorial b y en el vídeo anterior
nosotros vimos cómo hacer esto verdad
esencialmente lo que tenemos que
recordar es que el rotacional se puede
calcular como el gradiente cruz nuestro
campo vectorial ve y sólo para los por
si no recuerdas qué es lo que vimos en
el vídeo anterior el gradiente es este
vector que tiene puros operadores
diferenciales verdad derivada parcial
x la derivada de respecto de ye y la
derivada parcial con respecto de z y ya
sabemos que en realidad no es un vector
como tal pero nos ayuda a acordarnos de
todos estos operadores verdad y ahora
hacemos el producto cruz con nuestro
vector b es decir no con nuestro campo
vectorial b que se calcula como equis
porque en la primera componente coseno
de zeta en la segunda componente y se
está cuadrada más en la tercera
componente y por supuesto pues hay que
saber muy bien cómo se interpreta este
producto cruz si no recuerdas muy bien
qué es lo que hicimos pues sé que el
vídeo anterior verdad pero esencialmente
este producto cruz corresponde aún a una
especie de determinante que en realidad
no es un determinante como tal porque no
es una matriz con números pero vamos a
seguir esencialmente el mismo paso que
con un determinante tradicional verdad
entonces esto sería él
de una matriz en donde tenemos primero
nuestros vectores canónicos y unitarios
y jk verdad luego ponemos las
componentes de nuestro primer vector que
sería el vector nav la verdad que sería
parcial respecto de x parcial respecto
del parcial respecto de z y luego
tomamos las componentes de nuestro campo
vectorial que es el segundo vector
verdad entonces sería x coseno de z y se
está cuadrada más y muy bien entonces
vamos a calcular esta especie de
determinante aunque entonces para
calcular lo tomamos primero esta entrada
y multiplicamos por el por el
determinante de esta sub matriz restante
verdad entonces tendríamos el vector y
que multiplica a la derivada parcial con
respecto de y dc está cuadrada más y
entonces al derivar esto con respecto de
bueno la derivada de zeta cuadrada es
cero porque es una constante para fines
de derivar con respecto de iu y la
derivada de i
1 verdad entonces tendremos simplemente
1 - la derivada con respecto de zeta de
coseno de 7 y nosotros sabemos que la
derivada de cocina de zeta es menos el
seno de zeta muy bien entonces aquí
tenemos nuestro nuestro primer término y
ahora ponemos un menos verdad
- j porque recordemos que con el
determinante vamos alternando signos más
menos más muy bien entonces ahora para
esto necesitamos calcular el
determinante de la matriz que resta de
estas dos columnas verdad simplemente
quitamos la columna y la fila
correspondiente a j entonces si
derivamos con respecto a x se está
cuadrada más entonces obtenemos un 0
verdad porque nada de esto depende de x
son constantes para fines de derivar con
respecto de x y ahora restamos la
derivada con respecto de zeta de x por
ye y es el mismo caso verdad no dependen
explícitamente de z entonces
esto estuvo muy fácil y finalmente ya
que hicimos este término ahora vamos a
hacer el término con la verdad y con acá
lo único que tenemos que hacer es
multiplicar por el determinante de esta
sub matriz entonces al derivar coseno de
zeta con respecto de x obtenemos 00 - la
derivada con respecto de ye de x por y
entonces x es constante derivamos ye y
nos da 1 y entonces obtenemos
simplemente x verdad entonces con esto
ya podemos calcular digamos esto en él
si ya sería nuestro rotacional pero como
a mí me gusta más verlo digamos en un
vector verdad de columna entonces
podríamos decir que el rotacional de
nuestro de campo vectorial ve por
supuesto evaluado en el punto equis y
esta verdad será un vector
tridimensional
un vector tridimensional en donde la
primera componente sería uno más seno de
zeta uno más el seno de zeta también
tendríamos en la segunda componente cero
verdad aquí tendríamos que tener cuidado
con este signo verdad aquí teníamos un c
- y pues tendríamos que cambiar el signo
de lo que sea que nos dé aquí adentro en
este caso fue cero entonces no importa
y finalmente tendríamos menos x en la
última componente verdad y está esto que
encontramos aquí es justamente el
rotacional de la función en el punto x 7
y en general así es como se calcula el
rotacional de un campo vectorial lo
único que tenemos que acordarnos es que
se calcula como el producto cruz de
nuestro habla con el campo vectorial de
verdad entonces recordemos un habla es
justamente este vector de operadores
diferenciales y en esencia esto nos
lleva a calcular 6 derivadas parciales
distintas
finalmente obtenemos algo más o menos
así en cualquier ejemplo que tú quieras
considerar